bonsoir merci l'invitation est-ce que
c'était un emploi que vous aviez en tête
est-ce que c'était quelque chose que
vous aviez envie de faire de vous
joindre Hydro-Québec
juste à temps pour moi donc c'est quand
tu dis les as saling donc j'ai annoncé
en décembre Queen je termine le premier
juin puis en début d'année au cours du
printemps on a commencé à parler avec
avec la présidente du conseil actuel
puis le gouvernement ultimement puis je
suis vraiment emballé par ce défi je
suis content de venir contribuer vous
êtes une grande spécialiste des réseaux
télécoms et tout ça va ryzen vidéo tronc
il y a des similitudes quand même
d'abord des réseaux des clients des
entreprises est-ce que donc vous vous
sentez quand même en territoire un peu
connu dans la gestion de ces choses là
je pense vous avez bien touché le point
c'est ça que je rentre avec beaucoup
d'humilité là j'ai beaucoup à apprendre
à l'énergie mais ce qui me rassure et
j'ai passé quand même du temps et
derrière dans les derniers jours c'est
ma voix avec avec les différents membres
de la direction puis il y a vraiment des
termes qui me revient à Me David il
avait nommé le titre des grands
infrastructures des grands déploiements
on parle de redondance de réseau perte
de résilience du réseau ce sont des
termes que je connais bien et comment
louer les ressources et grands chantiers
déploiement qu'on va monétiser mais
qu'on va rentabiliser sur des vingtaine
d'années donc c'est sûr que je me sens
en territoire connu mais aussi l'autre
chose c'est que je deviens président du
conseil je n'aurais pas été PDG
l'Hydro-Québec donc donc si mon rôle au
quotidien là ça sera pas de gérer les
opérations de l'organisation mais
justement je m'en allais là mais vous
avez aussi une expérience avec les
clients de redéfinir avec des parties à
vidéotrons après
l'espèce de respect du client puis des
interfaces plus modernes avec la
clientèle peut-être qu'il est au Québec
pourrait prendre quelques idées mais
justement vous le dites vous-même je
m'en vais pas PDG on vous a offert
d'être la grande patronne PDG pourquoi
ça vous intéresse pas pourquoi vous avez
pas voulu sauter totalement dans
l'aventure si je puis dire
[Musique]
de rentrer dans la course à la direction
mais à un moment donné il y a des
moments dans notre carrière ou c'est
quoi le temps pour moi je me sens
vraiment plus confortable et interpellé
par le rôle de président du conseil de
toute façon on a entendu dans les médias
le gouvernement va nommer sous peu
comprendrez que j'ai fait mes devoirs
donc je connais la courte liste je pense
qu'on va être en super bonne main peu
importe le candidat qui va être retenu
parce que sinon c'est le gouvernement
qui choisit donc c'est vraiment ça rien
à voir avec pas vouloir c'est plus on
arrive à des étales de notre vie et puis
c'est ça qui m'interpelle pour le moment
donc je pense que je vais vraiment
pouvoir jouer un rôle
à ce niveau là puis je vais je vais
faire mon groupe donc on vous a présenté
la courte liste donc vous êtes à l'aise
de travailler avec soit un ou l'autre
des candidats de la candidate qui sera
choisi
absolument c'est super important à
un rôle comme ça quand il y a pas une
chimie ou un aliment avec avec le PDG la
PDG et donc oui on va être en très bonne
main vous parlez de chimie avec la PDG à
la chimie avec le gouvernement aussi bon
sophie Brochu je referai pas toute la
saga mais
clairement
elle a des moments donnés à trouver
difficile certaines interférences ou
certains est-ce que là-dessus vous avez
fait le point avec l'actionnaire
principal le Premier ministre le
ministre fait du début est-ce que vous
avez les coups de France est-ce que vous
êtes confortable avec la direction où ça
va Hydro-Québec
oui en fait ce qui est important c'est
de comprendre l'aliment ce qu'un aliment
philosophique qu'est-ce qu'un alignement
sur les grands enjeux les grandes
priorités je pense que sont très claires
là c'est priorités là puis l'ensemble de
la communauté est conscient par la suite
c'est comment le mal est humain prend la
décision pour faire face aux besoins
énergétiques du Sud si on parle de
doubler la capacité énergétique donc
c'est majeur on parle de décarboner le
Québec c'est une opportunité
exceptionnelle bien sûr il y a aussi la
gestion efficace de l'énergie comment on
fait ça
toute la notion d'impact sur la
communauté sur sur l'environnement
puis tout ce qui est résilience on a
parlé tantôt que les réseaux
technologies mais c'est le même principe
la pérennité de ces réseaux là je pense
qu'on a eu ces grandes discussions là
moi c'est important pour moi de
comprendre s'il y avait un aliment par
la suite que j'ai très très bien senti
et sérieux j'aurais pas accepté le poste
et qui en respect il va avoir un respect
il y a des talents exceptionnel à
Hydro-Québec j'ai eu la chance de
m'asseoir avec quelques-uns entre eux et
je comprends qu'on est à je veux pas
dire environ mais on a des grandes
décisions à prendre c'est
une histoire pour Hydro-Québec et j'ai
très très confiant que les gens en place
un pouvoir moi-même on va faire nos
devoirs puis on va prendre les bonnes
décisions une nouvelle rencontre avec
l'histoire c'est bien dit c'est un peu
seul on a l'impression que il y a un
nouveau chapitre qui commence à s'écrire
et que on va multiplier qu'on doit
accélérer les projets plus de production
il y a le virage énergétique bien sûr
mais il y a des gens qui disent est-ce
qu'on fait tout ça pour accroître les
exportations est-ce qu'on fait tout ça
pour nos besoins à nous il y a un
équilibre comment vous situez là-dedans
parce que bon oui ça fait partie de
toutes les analyses qui sont sur la
table une chose est certaine il va
falloir faire des choix donc je me sens
pas à l'aise avant même de débuter mon
mandat avant de m'asseoir avec le PDG
pour se faire une taille bien sûr on va
réfléchir rapidement et un sentiment
d'urgence je pense que tout le monde est
très conscient de ça mais encore là
comme je le disais je pense qu'il va
falloir prendre des bonnes décisions des
décisions pour nous les générations
futures donc les choix qu'on fait
aujourd'hui là ils vont impacter dans
les 20 et 45 ans prochaines années comme
les choix qui ont été faits par nos
prédécesseurs donc
à suivre des élèves vous êtes à New York
je disais vous avez été vous terminez
est-ce que vous allez re déménager ici
est-ce que vous pouvez faire vous serez
entre New York et Montréal comment ça va
fonctionner
[Musique]
ma famille est là on n'a pas on est
resté canadien québécois le temps que
j'étais ici le 2 ans donc je suis très
heureuse de rentrer à la maison ça va
être plus simple pour les soucis de
famille je vous dirais parce que plus de
la logistique ok donc je reviens je
reviens avec la même question que je
vous entends je vous écoute vous avez
réfléchi sur Hydro-Québec sur le rôle le
poste de PDG il n'y a pas une soirée ou
deux vous a dit ça me tente
ça sert à rien de répondre à cette
question là parce que j'étais nommée
hier très très heureuse de cette
nomination là
pour poser la question maintenant
Brouillette président du conseil
d'administration d'Hydro-Québec on va se
reparler merci beaucoup merci à la
prochaine au revoir